[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر في موريتانيا ان عبد الله
سنوسي مدير المخابرات الليبيه السابق
اعتقل على اراضيها لدى وصوله مطار العاصمه
وفيما لم يعرف لمن سيسلم الرجل اكد الناطق
باسم الحكومه الانتقاليه الليبيه اعتقال
سنوسي المطلوب لحكومه طرابلس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ولمحكمة
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما الاهميه التي ينطوي عليها
اعتقال سنوسي سواء في داخل ليبيا او
خارجها وما الخيارات المتاحه للتعامل مع
سنوسي وهو المطلوب محليا
[موسيقى]
وللعدالة
راس اخر من رؤوس النظام القذافي يسقط عبد
الله سنوسي في قبضه السلطات الموريتانيه
للرجل في ذاكره الليبيين مساحه واسعه
ومرير فقد كان ظل القذافي وذراعه للبطش
بخصومه وفي رقبته يعلق الليبيون او يعلقون
مجزره سجن بوسليم وهو مدبر معركه القذافي
ضد الثوار حتى سقوط طرابلس غير ان اعتقال
سنوسي لن يشكل على الارج متغيرا جوهريا في
المعادله الداخليه فقد سقط من قبله
القذافي نفسه وبدعه من اولاده بين قتيل
ومعتقل قادما على متن رحله جويه اتيه من
المغرب انتهت مسيره التخفي بالرجل القوي
لمخابرات نظام القذافي عبد الله سنوسي
معتقلا لدى السلطات الموريتانيه مخزن
للاسرار يعني الكثير لجهات عده يتقدم
ليبيون الذين ينتظرون من السنوسي ان يميت
اللثام عن خفايا احداث هامه طبعت ذاكرتهم
الحديثه لعل اهمها مجزره سجن بوسليم التي
راح ضحيتها ازيد من 1200 سجين وثقتها
تقارير المنظمات الحقوقيه المحليه
والدوليه للدول الغربيه دين هي الاخرى في
رقبه عبد الله سنوسي اسم تردد في عدد من
الهجمات التي تعرضت لها مصالحها من اهمها
اسقاط طائره مدنيه فرنسيه في اجواء النيجر
دون استبعاد ان تكون له يد او معلومات
هامه ترتبط باسقاط طائره امريكيه سنه
1988 فوق لوكربي الواقعه في الاراضي
الاسكتلنديه عربيا يبقى لبنان اهم
المعنيين باعتقال عبد الله سنوسي ذلك انه
رغم مرور اكثر من سنه على سقوط نظام
القذافي لم تتكشف الحقيقه كامله حول
اختفاء مؤسس حركه امل الشيعيه الصدر الذي
دعاه القذافي لزياره ليبيا عام 78 لتنقطع
اخباره منذ ذلك الوقت وسط شكوك قويه بوقوف
مخابرات نظام العقيد وراء هذا الملف
تجاوزت عجله الاحداث في ليبيا الجديده عبد
الله سنوسي واخذت بالتالي كثيرا من بريق
القبض عليه لكنها مع ذلك ابقت عليه صيدا
معلوماتيا ثمينا يحتاجه القضاء المحلي
والدولي ليستكمل مكونات ما بات يعرف
بالملف الليبي خصه في جزئه الاحدث والاهم
وهو التجاوزات الخطيره التي اقترفت اثر
اندلاع الثوره الليبيه كالتصفيف خارج
القانون ودون محاكمات واغتصاب النساء
وتعذيب المعتقلين وتجنيد الاطفال وجلب
المرتزقه للاستعانه بهم في قمع الثوار سقط
النظام الليبي لكن السؤال بقي قائما هل
باحت حقبه القذاف بكل اسرارها عبد الله
سنوسي يعرف ولا شك
الاجابه نطق م الحكومه الانتقاليه الليبيه
ناصر المانع الذي اكد نبا الاعتقال قال ان
في مؤتمر صحفي طبعا قال ان الاتصالات
جاريه مع السلطات الموريتانيه لتسلم
سنوسي من خلال مذكره النائب العام مذكره
امر القبض على عبد الله
السنوسي تم
تسليم هذه المذكره الى السلطات
الموريتانيه من خلال مك متب الشرطه
الدوليه الانتربول في ليبيا واللي بدوره
سلم مذكره القبض الى السلطات
الموريتانيه لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
عمان الدكتور راضي العبدلات وهو استاذ
القانون الدولي في جامعه الزيتونه ومعنا
ايضا من بنغازي محمد جويلي وهو المعتقل
السابق في سجن بوسليم واحد مفاوضي عبد
الله سنوسي لانهاء اضراب السجناء الذي حصل
ابان مجزره بوسليم ومعنا ايضا من طرابلس
الدكتور مصطفى ابو شاقور وهو النائب الاول
لرئيس الوزراء الليبي نرحب بضيوفنا الكرام
ولعل اول سؤال نطرحه على الدكتور مصطفى
ابو شاقور يعني في عده مرات جرى الاعلان
عن اعتقال او حتى مقتل السنوسي ليتبين
لاحقا عدم صحه تلك الاخبار كيف تاكدت
وبايه اليه تاكدت بان المعتقل في
موريتانيا هو فعلا عبد الله
سنوسي يبدو ان ضيفنا ليس في الاستماع بعد
ريث ما يجهز نتحول ربما باول سؤال الى
بنغازي
واسيد محمد الجويلي وهو المعتقل السابق في
سجن بو سليم كاحد المعتقلين في ابان مجزره
بو سليم واحد المفاوضين ايضا بخصوصها كيف
تلقيت نبا اعتقال عبد الله السنوسي وما
الذي يمثله لكافه الليبيين في هذه
المرحله بسم الله الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه ومن
والاه ثم اما بعد لا شك ان هذا الخبر
السار يمثل خبرا سارا اولا
لضحايا هذه المجزره الرهيبه لاسرهم التي
عانت الامرين اولا من كتمان هذا الخبر
عنهم وما تكلفوهم من عناء وشطط وظلم قبل
ان يعرفوا مصير ابنائهم ثم ان هذا الخبر
السار هو مسر لكل الليبيين لما اقترفت يد
هذا المجرم من جرائم كان مسؤول عنها كل
الجرائم التي وقعت للشعب الليبي كان هو
الخنجر المنفذ
[تصفيق]
لطاغية هو كاتم اسراره ومنفذ كل جرائمه
وكل الجرائم التي حدثت لشعبنا الليبي من
قمع له عبر اربعه عقود كان هذا المجرم هو
المنفذ والمشرف عليها وهو الذي اعتاد ان
يريق الدماء البريئه بدم بارد فهو لا شك
خبر سار لكل ليبيين
خبر يمكن ان يمثله نعم سيد جويلي ما الذي
يمكن ان يمثل كاهيه بخصوص هذه المجزره
وماذا يكون قد حصل بخصوص مصير من لقوا
حتفهم او حتى الذين لا يعرف مصيرهم الى حد
الان ايه اهميه بالنسبه للاعتقال وما الذي
يمكن ان يقدمه كمعلومات
منذ ان وقعت هذه الحادثه من لحظاتها
الاولى كان هذا المجرم هو اول من وصل الى
سجن ابي سليم وهو الذي اشرف على اداره
الكتائب التي حاصرت السجن وصعدت فوق بواب
ه واسواره وابراجه ثم هو الذي اخذ يراقب
ويشرف على هذا الامر من المفاوضات الى ان
تمت الجريمه بتصفيه هذه الاعداد هذه
المئات من السجناء العزل فهو لا شك لديه
كل التفاصيل والدقائق وكيف تلقى الاوامر
من سيده وكيف نفذها وكيف نكث ما وعد به
السجناء من انهم سيكونون امنين بعد بعد ان
فاوضنا نعم سيد الجيلي هو بالفعل يوصف
كخزان معلومات للقذافي ونظامه دعنا نعود
الان للدكتور مصطفى الذي بات جاهزا معنا
ونسال عن كيفيه التاكد ووفق ايه اليه بان
الذي اعتقل هذه المره خلافا لمرات عده
سابقه هو بالفعل عبد الله
سنوسي نعم مساء الخير مساء النور نعم يعني
نعم هو اي تتاكد هذا كان عن طريق الحكومه
الموريتانيه التي اكدت لنا ان الذي اعتق
هو عبد الله السنوسي طبعا المرات الماضيه
كانت كلها مجرد اشاعات لكن هذه المره هي
حقيقه واقعه وهذا المجرم يعني اخيرا قد
اعتقل اي و سوف نطالب به وقد طالبنا
الحكومه الموريتانيه با قبل المطالبه
دكتور مصطفى رجاء هل سترسل او تفدونى من
يتحقق فعلا من هويته حتى يقطع الشك
باليقين نعم نعم دون شك نعم نعم يعني
سيكون هناك من من سيتحقق من هويته وفي نفس
الوقت ايضا المطالبه بتسليمه للحكومه
الليبيه ليواجه العداله لان هذا الرجل
ارتكب جرائم بشعه في حق الشعب الليبي خلال
40 سنه فجاء حان الوقت لكي يقف امام
المحكمه وحاكمه عادله على هذه الجرائم
اللي ارتكبها يعني نعم المطالبه بتسليمه
من قبل السلطات الموريتانيا لحد الان كيف
تسير الامور بهذا الاتجاه هل تعتقدون بان
هناك سلاسه في الموضوع خاصه ان علمنا
ويعلم المشاهد بان الاعتراف بالمجلس
الانتقالي من قبل موريتانيا لم تتم سوى في
نوفمبر الماضي
ا نعم لكن الان حقيقه العلاقات بين ليبيا
وموريتانيا علاقات يعني تحسنت كثيرا
الاسبوع الماضي وزير الداخليه الموريتاني
ووفد يعني شارك في المؤتمر امن الحدود
الذي عقد في طرابلس و و وونعم فهذه
العلاقات حقيقه علاقه جيده وحقيقه هو حتى
الاعتقال ذاته نرى ان هو نتيجه لتحسن هذه
العلاقات ما بين ليبيا وموريتانيا
اها لعل ربما ل المشاهد بعض الفضول لمعرفه
كيف تمت عمليه الاعتقال خاصه وانه ربما
استطاع التخفي والهرب لمده طويله وبالتالي
السؤال هل كان للجانب الليبي اي اسهام في
هذه العمليه هل كان متخفيا ماذا عن تفاصيل
الاعتقال نعم هو حقيقه التفاصيل الان يعني
ليست يعني لدينا كامله لكن الحكومه
الموريتانيه اخبرتنا بان هو عندما وصل الى
مطار نواكشوط من
المغرب قام التعرف عليه يعني وتم اعتقاله
يعني نعم ا نتحول الان ربما الى عمان
ونسال على جانب اخر مهم هو الجانب
القانوني واسال الدكتور راضي العبدلات عن
الوضع القانوني لعبد الله السنوسي
الان بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اهنئ الشعب
الليبي بالقاء القبض على هذا السفاح
المجرم واترحم على شهداء الثوره الليبيه
واتمنى للجرحى الشفاء العاجل وتحيه لكل
اسره وطفل وشيخ في ليبيا الثوره باعتقادي
ان الحكومه الموريتانيه ملزمه بتسليم هذا
السفاح الى السلطات الليبيه استنادا الى
توقيعها الى اتفاقيه الرياض لعام
983 وهي اتفاقيه التعاون القضائي بين
والقانوني بين الدول العربيه واستنادا الى
الماده 46 و47 من هذه الاتفاقيه تلزم هذه
الاتفاقيه الحكومه الموريتانيه تسليم هذا
المجرم اذا طلبت السلطات الليبيه ذلك في
ملف يعرف بملف الاسترداد اي تسليم
المجرمين الدكتور راضي دكتور راضي فقط نود
ان نقف معك هنا عند هذه النقطه نود
الاستفاده قدر الامكان ل بين سابقه
البغدادي المحمودي المتواجد في تونس نعلم
كل التعقيدات التي جرت المطالبات من قبل
السلطات الليبيه التلكؤ والرفض في بعض
الاحيان قيل من قبل السلطات التونسيه ما
الذي يجعل الامر سالسا وممكنا هذه المره
باعتقادك في خصوص موريتانيا ا باعتقادي
باعتقادي انه يجب كان تسليم راس لرئيس
الوزراء السابق من تونس الى ليبيا ولكن
احتجت السلطات التونسيه فيما يتعلق بعدم
استقلال القضاء الليبي واعتبار ان ليبيا
الان هي في طور تشكيل ما يسمى المؤسسات
وهل اختلف الموض الان رئيس الوزراء هنا
هذه مساله جدليه في القانون الدولي سوف
اتحدث عنها بعد قليل على اعتبار انه
اتفاقيه الرياض لعام
1983 تلزم موريتانيا بتسليم المجرم
السانوسي الى السلطات الليبيه على اعتبار
ان كل شروط هي متوافره وما على السلطات
الليبيه الا ان تقدم ما يسمى ملف التسليم
وملف التسليم يجب ان يمر باجراءات قضائيه
داخليه في ليبيا وصولا الى وزاره الخارجيه
الليبيه التي سوف تق تسلمه الى موريتانيا
لكن المشكله الاساسيه تكمن فيما اذا كان
هناك توفر المعايير القانونيه الدوليه
للمحاكمه العادله في ليبيا وهذه مساله
مثاره جدل على اعتبار انه هذه المعايير
تنطلق انه يجب ان يكون اولا استقلال
القضاء بمعنى استقلال السلطه القضائيه عن
السلطه التنفيذيه والسلطه التشريعيه ثانيا
استقلال القضاء واستقلال القضاه نفسهم عن
ضمانات المحاكمه واقصد بذلك ضمانات حق
الدفاع رابعا وجود محامي خامسا ان يكون
الحكم مسببا سادسا ان يكون الحكم قابلا
للاستئناف سابعا هي على نيه المحاكمه
وثامن ان يكون القرار قطعي ونهائي هناك
جدل واسع وكبير جدا في توفر اودم توفر هذه
الضمانات لدى السلطات ال نتوقف تحديدا عند
هذه النقطه دكتور عبد اللاد وسنحل كل هذه
النقاط التي ذكرت بخصوص امكانيه تو
معادله عادله ل عبد الله السنوسي في ليبيا
لكن بعد فاصل قصير سوف نطرح هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
انتظرونا اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي
تتناولوا ابعاد اعتقال السلطات
الموريتانيه عبد الله سنوسي مدير
المخابرات الليبيه السابق اعود دكتور
مصطفى وما طرحه الدكتور العبدلات بخصوص
الشروط الثمانيه
لتوفير محاكمه عادله لعبد الله السنوسي
واطرح السؤال هنا الذي يقع ربما في خضم
جدل واسع بخصوص هذه النقطه هل بامكان
ليبيا الان وفي ظل الظروف الحاليه فعلا
تقديم محاكمه عادله
للسنوسي نعم نعم يعني الان الظروف في
ليبيا مواليه اولا الشروط اللي ذكرها
الاستاذ الفاضل نحن حرصنا من من البدايه
ان يكون القضاء هو قضاء مستقل عن السلطه
التشريعيه والتنفيذيه ا ايضا الامن الان
في في ليبيا مستتب وايضا بون شك يعني احنا
سن سيكون هناك واحنا حريصين على ان ان هذه
المحاكمات تكون محاكمات عادله بالمعايير
الدوليه ويشارك فيها مراقبون من من من اي
من محكمه العدد الد الدوليه والجنايات
الدوليه وايضا ان ان يتاح ل
ل عبد الله السنوسي وسواه ان يكون لهم
يعني محامين يدافعوا عن عن عنهم فاحنا
حريصين ان تكون هذه الصوره هي صوره ليبيا
الجديده ان حتى اكبر مجرم في حق الشعب
ليبي انه يحاكم محاكمه عادله وهذه حقيقه
هي تحول مهم في في بالنسبه لليبيا في في
هذه الفتره وفي المستقبل يعني اتحول لواحد
من المتضررين
مباشره مما او من ممارسات النظام السابق
وتحديدا مما يشار اليه عن مسؤوليه مباشره
لعبد الله السنوسي في مجزره بو سليم
والسيد الجويلي سيد الجويلي يعني اي ايهما
الاهم بالنسبه اليكم ان يحاكم عبد الله
سنوسي عن مسؤوليته لما اقترف ابان مجزره
سجن بليم ام ان يحاكم على كل ما اشير عن
مسؤوليه مباشره للرجل ايضا في الاحداث
التي صاحبت الثوره الليبيه والانتهاكات
ايضا نعم في هذا المقام لابد ان نذكر بان
مزره بوسليم كان لها دور اساسي ومفصلي في
قيام ثوره الساب عشر من فبراير فقد كانت
اسر شهداء هذه المجزره يخرجون كل سبت في
ميادين بني غازي
ويجوبون مطالبه بحقوق ابنائهم يريدون ان
يعرفوا مصير هؤلاء الابناء كيف ق تل
يريدون تسليم جثامينهم يريدون ان يعرفوا
كيف ال الامر الى ما ال اليه وذلك كان في
وجود عبد الله السنوسي وكان في وجود
الطاغيه وكان ذلك في ظاهره عملا عبثيا لكن
هذه هذا الحراك الذي قامت به هذه الاسر من
خلال
رابطه شهداء بوسليم كان قد اجج الثوره
وكان سببا في ان يطالب الشعب الليبي بحقه
حتى تكرر ذلك في صوره ثانيه عندما ذهب
الليبيون الى سفاره الايطاليه مناصرين
لرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم فاطلقت
عليهم النار وقتل من قتل منهم هاتان
المحطتان كان لهما تاثير كبير في تاجد
الثوره الساب عشر من الساب من فبراير حتى
لا نستطيع ان نقول انهما الارهاص اللتان
كانتا الشراره لهذه الثوره ومنن ثم فان
مصدره ابو سليم تعتبر رمزا من رموز هذه
الثوره وقضيه معرفه ملابسات
ذات دلاله قصوى في قضيه الجرائم والملفات
التي يحفل بها راس هذا المجرم ا سيد
الجويلي نرجو ان تبقى معنا نتحول ربما
لدكتور راضي العبدلات ونريد الاضاءه مره
اخرى على الجانب القانوني لعلك سمعت دكتور
تلك المراره من ضحايا مجزره سجن ابو سليم
لكن الرجل ايضا مطلوب من قبل محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه في قضايا وفرنسا ايضا
التي تطالب به الان وهي اخر المنظمين كما
ورد في خبر عاجل بعبد الله
السنوسي سؤالنا هو هذه المطالبه من قبل
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه والمطالبه الشعبيه
ليبيا بخصوص مجزره بوسليم الا يمكن ان
تخلق نزاعا بين الطرفين بخصوص الرجل تماما
كما سمعنا فيما يخص سيف الاسلام القذافي
الذي لا يزال مصيره الى لحد الان
معلقا
ا بطبيعه الحال ليس هناك جدال في ان
موريتانيا ليست موقعه لاتفاقيه الجنائيه
الدوليه وكذلك ليبيا ليست موقعه الاتفاقيه
الجنائيه الدوليه اي اتفاقيه روما لعام
2002 ا وبالتالي هذهه الاتفاقيه غير ملزمه
اطلاقا الى السلطات الليبيه وغير ملزمه
اطلاقا الى موريتانيا وموريتانيا ملزمه
بتنفيذ الاتفاقيات والمعاهدات استنادا
لاتفاقيه فينا لعام 190 68 واقصد بذلك
اتفاقيه الرياض المعقوده بين الدول
العربيه وعليها ان تسلم هذا السفاح الى
ليبيا ولكن اذا سلم هذا السفاح الى ليبيا
بامكان السلطات الليبيه ان تمارس اختصاص
ولاياتها الوطنيه لمحاكم السيف الاسلام
وايضا السنوسي على اراضيها وضمن محاكمها
استنادا الى الماده 80 من اتفاقيه روما
التي تعطي الاختصاص والاولويه للمحاكم
الوطنيه طالما ان ليبيا وموريتانيا ليس
طرفا في الاتفاقيه ولكن يمكن لليبيا اذا
ارادت وهذا قرار وطني داخلي ليبي ان تتخلى
عن ولايتها الوطنيه لمحاكمه السنوسي
واسلام القذافي وتسليمهما الى المحكمه
الجنائيه
الدوليه فرنسا الان على الخط وكن هذا ام
نعم دخول فرنسا على الخط الان ومطالبتها
ايضا بتسلم عبد الله سنوسي والجميع يعرف
الخلفيه وهي الطائره الفرنسيه التي سقطت
والاتهامات الموجهه بهذا الخصوص ما الذي
يضيفه للقضيه
ولابعدها تعطى الاولويه الى الى الدوله
التي تحمل جنسيتها اي ليبيا وتعطي
الاولويه الى الدوله التي ارتكب هذا الشخص
فيها افعالها والافعال الجرميه التي قام
بها وباعتقادي ان السنوسي يحمل الجنسيه
الليبيه والق السنوسي ارتكب جرائم كثيره
جدا في ليبيا وارتكب جرائم كبيره جدا بحق
الشعب الليبي في الداخل والخارج وبحق
المعارضين وجلب حتى المعارضين من الخارج
الى الداخل وبالتالي الاولويه في مثل هذه
الحاله واستناد لاتفاقيه الرياض في الماده
48 تعطى الاولويه الى الدوله التي يحمل
جنسيتها المتهم والدوله التي قام هذا
المتهم بارتكاب الجرائم في اراضيها وفي
اعتقادي هنا الاولويه اوليه لليبيا من
وجهه نظرك دكتور وضح تماما الو الم
القانون الدولي وجهه نظر القانون الدولي
وليست وجهه نظري الشخصيه نظر القانونيه
طبعا وهذا ما اردناه كخبير طبعا اشكرك الى
هذه اللحظه دعنا نتحول فيما بقي ربما من
دقائق للدكتور مصطفى نود بعيدا عن هذا
الجدل القانوني خريطه التحرك لرجل قبل
قرابه اسبوع او اكثر بقليل قيل بانه كان
في مالي اليوم القي القبض عليه في
موريتانيا قادما من المغرب هذا التحرك هذه
الخريطه ما الذي يمكن ان نقراها منها يعني
دون شك يعني عبد الله السنوسي كان يعني في
كل هذه الفتره يحاول هو وبقيه اتباع ال
النظام السابق محاوله تاجيج عدم الاستقرار
في داخل ليبيا ويحاول هو وبعض
عوانه لكي
يعني لا يكون فيه استقرار في داخل في داخل
ليبيا فهو بون شك يعني يتصل بما بقي من
اعوان القدافي اللي موجودين في الخارج
وبعضهم موجودين في المغرب بناء على
تحليلات تقول ذلك بان هناك محاولات اتصال
ام بناء على
معلومات لا لا لا بناء على معلومات بون شك
يعني نعم يعني هو يعني وجوده في مالي كان
طبعا في في الفتره الماضيه ويعني يتحرك
وهناك مجموعات في بعض البلدان الاخرى اللي
هو على الاتصال بها فهذا
هو السلوسي هو يعني رجل مجرم ويعرف ان هو
العداله تلاحقه فيعمل بقدر بكل ما يستطيع
ان ان يؤثر في داخل الامن في داخل ليبيا
ويحاول هذه المحاولات ولكن طبعا ربنا اوقع
به وهو الان يعني في معتقل وسيكون في ل ان
شاء الله قريبا لكي يواجه الشعب الليبي
والجرائم اللي ارتكبها امام الشعب الليبي
و ارتكبها على 40 سنه يعني لاخر يوم في
ليبيا هو كان يرتقب جرائم يعني في عجاله
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه ستسلم وه لها ام
لا اولا هو يواجه المحاكمه في ليبيا اولا
وبعد ذلك يكون امر اخر يعني اشكر يرتكب
هذه الجرائم في داخل ليبيا وسيحاكم هنا
يعني اشكرك جزي الشكر الدكتور مصطفى ابو
شاقور النائب الاول لرئيس الوزراء الليبي
كنت معنا من طرابلس كما نشكر ضيفنا من
عمان الدكتور راضي العبدلات استاذ القانون
الدولي في جامعه الزيتونه ونشكر ضيفنا من
بنغازي محمد جويلي المعتقل السابق في سجن
بوسليم واحد مفوضي عبد الله سنوسي لانهاء
اضراب السجناء الذي حصل ابان مجزره سجن
بوسليم بهذا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج م وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
تعالى في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
p